yeah
yeah so this is when i was
at microsoft
working on the assistive technology
working on seeing ai
in general i was working on
generating language from images
and what i was starting to see
was just how
just how i guess i would say lopsided
data was
just they just it data just really
represents a subset of the world as it
is and it really influences what a model
will say
so
i was starting to run into issues where
white people would be described as
people and black people would be
described as black people
so like as if white was a default and
black was a marked
character um characteristic so
that was concerning to me
there was a there was sort of an aha
moment where
i was feeding my system
a sequence of images getting it to talk
about more of like a story of what's
happening
and i fed it some images about this
massive blast
at a factory
where a lot of people worked it was
called the hempstead blast
and you could see from the sequence of
images
that the person taking the picture
was on like the second or third story
looking out at the blast and the blast
was very close to this person and you
could see there was the news on in the
corner and it was like talking about the
blast and the view from the news was
basically like the same view that this
person had
so it was just like this really dire
intense moment
and i i fed it through the system and
the system was like this is awesome this
is a great view this is beautiful and
you're like
it is a great view
of this horrible scene right but what's
important here is that people might be
dying this is a massive destructive
explosion
yeah the thing is when you're learning
from images people don't tend to take
pictures of horrible things people take
images of like going to parties like
having fun sunsets things like that so
it had learned like oh i'm looking at
the sky i see like blue and red like
it's beautiful
and it just really struck me that that
was just one hop away from a system that
would potentially blow up buildings
because it thought it was beautiful
right you give something with that sort
of thinking
access to actions and now things can be
yeah
so that was really a moment for me where
i realized i didn't want to keep making
these systems do better on benchmarks i
wanted to fundamentally shift how we
were looking at these problems how we
were approaching data and analysis of
data how are we evaluating and all of
the factors that we were leaving out
with just these straightforward
pipelines
so that really became the shift to
ethical ai work